قيود كورونا تعود من جديد ولكن على
المسافرين من الصين فقط تحرك دولي اتجاه
الصين بعد تفتش السريع لكرونا من جديد مع
شكوكا في احصاء بكين الخاصه بالفيروس اذا
فرضت عده دول الزاميه فحوصات الكشف عن
الفيروس على المسافرين القديمين من الصين
منها امريكا والهند واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان وايطاليا وانضمت مؤخرا
الى القائمه اسبانيا التي تلزم تطعيم
الكامل او الزاميه الفحص وكاله الصحه
التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي قالت ان فرض
الفحوصات غير مبرر وغير ضروري لافته الى
ان الفحوصات اقل وفعاليه اذا فرضها كل بلد
اوروبي على حده الاجراءات الاحتياطيه التي
اتخذتها تلك الدول اعتبرها رئيس منظمه
الصحه العالميه بالمفهومه مع تشتت العالم
في مواجهه رفع القيود الصحيه في الصين
وسائل الاعلام صينيه وصفت قرارات الدول
الاوروبيه تمييزيه
النيه الحقيقيه هي تخرب جهود الصين على
مدى ثلاثه اعوام للسيطره على فيروس كورونا
ومهاجمه النظام البلاد
الارتفاع المفاجئ لاصابات كورونا بعد
التخلي عن سياسه الصين الصارمه المعروفه
بصفر كوفيت دفع بالصحه العالميه لطلب
المزيد من المعلومات التفصيليه لتقييم
الزياده الاخيره في الاصابات رشا خياطه
العربيه